the Democratic primary is incredibly
important because whoever wins it will
get the chance to take on Donald Trump
in 2020 there are a lot of Democrats who
fancy taking a shot at the incumbent
president by September the Democratic
Party rules will have whittled the field
down to a more manageable number
September is also the time when polls
start to become more accurate if you
look at past races the front-runner at
the moment is Joe Biden the best known
candidates in the field it was vice
president for eight years he was a
Senator for Delaware for a long time
he's run for president before name
recognition is incredibly important in
American politics and actually starting
with a famous name like Biden's is is a
great advantage he's seen as a centrist
from the party sort of moderate wing
thus far his campaign has been pretty
light on policy a large part of his
appeal really is the idea that put up
against Donald Trump he might be the
safest choice that comes with some risks
Biden is by no means a perfect candidate
he has a long political history that
people will be able to rake over he's
also a candidate prone to gaffes we've
seen in the past he's even older than
president Donald Trump his there are
some Democrats who feel that it might
not be smart to put an older man up
against Donald Trump it might be better
for the party to go for some sort of
generational contrast to pick a much
younger candidate who can make the
president look old and out of touch also
among the top tier of candidates is
Democratic senator Elizabeth Warren
Center from Massachusetts in a previous
life she was a professor at Harvard
University she has plans for everything
and they may be good plans they may be
bad plans but you cannot fool her for a
lack of detail she really stands out in
the field on that point she like Bernie
Sanders is in a sort of leftish part of
the party she's made the theme of her
campaign rethinking capitalism she's in
favor of universal health care she wants
to put workers on boards higher minimum
wage
and so forth I'm not sure there's room
for both her and senator Sanders
ultimately I think they're competing
against each other they will draw votes
from each other
you've got senator Bernie Sanders from
Vermont familiar figure to many people
from his run in the 2016 Democratic
primary where he was beaten by Hillary
Clinton
he's a self-avowed socialist something
that until quite recently was pretty
rare in the Democratic Party he's been
in favor of a lot of progressive
policies like universal health care long
before they became fashionable and
that's given him a certain amount of
credibility but science is still seen as
being a big risk as being too left-wing
for a lot of Americans or at least for a
lot of the states that a Democratic
presidential candidate would have to win
to have a realistic chance of getting to
the White House but I'm sure he'll be in
the race right to the end
Pete Bhoots judges the mayor of South
Bend Indiana he's doing well in the
polls at the moment he's popular
particularly among well-educated sort of
urban Democrats if you told me before
2016 that the mayor of a small
Midwestern town would be not only
running for president but would be in
with a shot of getting one of the major
party's nominations I would have thought
you were nuts and tried to sell you some
real estate but Donald Trump changed all
the rules boost Church is doing rather
well he has lots of policies for all
sorts of things one of the most striking
ones to my mind is that he'd like to put
an extra few justices on the Supreme
Court to try and counterbalance the
conservative justices who have been
placed there in the past couple of years
Kamla Harris is a Democratic senator
from California before she was a senator
she was prosecutor she's an interesting
candidate for a number of reasons if Joe
Biden slips up in some way during this
primary then who will benefit from that
it looks at the moment that Kamala
Harris might be the best place person to
benefit she's in a similar sort of Lane
in the party to Joe Biden but she has a
couple of other things going for her she
would be the first African American
woman to get the nomination so her
kandacy would have a certain kind of
history
dimension early in her candidacy she
attached herself to a lot of policies
from the progressive wing of the party
where it seemed like that was where the
energy really was before Joe Biden
stepped in so she said she was in favor
of Medicare for all for instance
debt-free college raise in the minimum
wage and so on one challenge for her is
relative to Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
she's really not particularly well known
around America then there's a whole
group of candidates behind that leading
group just to mention just a highlight a
smattering of the best ones better rorke
former congressman from El Paso border
town in southwest Texas he's best known
for having run Ted Cruz closed in 2018
when he ran for the Senate and he was
such a charismatic campaigner
that he attracted a lot of political
attention nationally a lot of donations
and his presidential primary run is kind
of a springboard from from that there's
Amy Klobuchar
the senator from Minnesota she's from
the moderate part of the party and the
strongest point in her favor really is
that she does well in the Midwest where
she's from
she out polled Hillary Clinton
substantially in her home state in
Minnesota when she was up for
re-election so if you were looking for a
woman at the top of the ticket and
somebody who might be able to win back
those key states in the Midwest that
Democrats lost to Republicans in 2016
then she might be a good place to look
there's Cory Booker Democratic senator
from New Jersey he's long been seen as a
rising star in the party he's got an
interesting record actually as mayor of
Newark and New Jersey particular as an
education reformer he tends not to talk
about that very much now because some of
the things he did annoyed teachers
unions who are an important constituency
in the Democratic primary but you know
he's somebody to take seriously as well
these primaries will partly be a
referendum on what sort of party the
Democratic Party is these days
ideologically there are a lot of people
who think that the party's moved to the
left if they're right about that then
you'd expect Bernie Sanders perhaps
Elizabeth Warren to do well there are a
lot of other people who argue no it
really hasn't the thing that Democrats
want most of all is to pick somebody
who's going to beat Donald Trump they're
not particularly ideological as a party
less ideological than Republicans and so
if that's the case you
look at somebody like Joe Biden Kamla
Harris perhaps Amy Klobuchar